I like to purposely wear thin bras to
work so my nipples show to get more tips
I found a dead bug in my bra it died
from pressure
hashtag big boob problems my secret I
never take my bra off during sex because
one of my nipples is bigger than the
other I put my phone in my bra when I
left the bathroom because I didn't have
pockets and accidentally boob dialed
someone once I sent a photo of my boobs
to my mom by mistake so I told her I
wanted her opinion on the bra I was
wearing I changed my bra in a confession
box in a Catholic Church in Ireland
I think the priest noticed sometimes
when I wear a push-up bra I get
distracted by my own cleavage I secretly
like it when people accidentally noticed
my nipple piercings at the gym through
my shirt flash sports bra I cried this
morning when I realized I forgot to
stuff my bra I secretly like it when my
bras visible through my shirt took up my
bra and traffic sorry dude I have
flashed I couldn't wait to get home I
was so uncomfortable I slipped off my
strapless bra in the middle of class
hope no one noticed when my bra and
panties match I really feel like I have
my life together I've never watched any
of my bras ever